En los próximos 18 minutos los voy a llevar en un viaje.
Es un viaje en el que tanto ustedes como yo hemos estado desde hace muchos años,
y comenzó hace unos 50 años, cuando los humanos salieron de nuestro planeta por primera vez.
En esos cincuenta años no sólo pusimos, literalmente, un pie en la Luna,
además hemos enviado sondas espaciales a todos los planetas (a los ocho)
y hemos aterrizado en asteroides, hemos ido al encuentro de cometas,
y en este mismo instante tenemos una nave espacial viajando hacia Plutón,
el cuerpo celeste anteriormente conocido como planeta.
Y todas estas misiones robóticas son parte de un viaje mayor para la humanidad:
un viaje para entender, para darnos cuenta de nuestro lugar en el cosmos
para entender algo de nuestros orígenes, y cómo la Tierra, nuestro planeta,
y nosotros, viviendo en él, llegamos a existir.
Y entre todos los lugares en el Sistema Solar a los que podríamos ir
y buscar respuestas a preguntas como esas,
está Saturno. Y hemos estado en Saturno antes -
visitamos Saturno a principios de los 80-
pero nuestras investigaciones de Saturno se han vuelto mucho más profundas y detalladas
desde que la nave Cassini, habiendo viajado a través del espacio interplanetario
durante siete años, se colocó en órbita alrededor de Saturno en el verano del 2004,
y se convirtió entonces en el punto de avanzada robótico más lejano
que la humanidad ha establecido alrededor del sol.
Bien, el sistema de Saturno es un sistema planetario muy rico.
Ofrece misterio, conocimiento científico y, como salta a la vista, una belleza incomparable,
y la investigación de este sistema tiene un gran alcance cósmico.
De hecho, sólo estudiando los anillos estamos aprendiendo mucho
sobre los discos de estrellas y gas que llamamos galaxias espirales.
Y aquí tenemos una preciosa imagen de la Nebulosa de Andrómeda,
que es la galaxia espiral más grande y más cercana a la Vía Láctea.
Y aquí vemos una bonita composición de la Galaxia Remolino,
tomada por el telescopio espacial Hubble.
Así que realmente el regreso a Saturno es parte de -y también es una metáfora
de- un viaje humano mayor
para entender la interconectividad entre todo lo que nos rodea,
y también cómo los humanos encajamos en esa imagen.
Y me duele no poder contarles todo lo que hemos aprendido con Cassini,
No puedo mostrarles todas las preciosas imágenes que hemos tomado
en los últimos dos años y medio, porque simplemente no tenemos suficiente tiempo.
Así que voy a concentrarme en dos de las historias más emocionantes
que han surgido en esta gran expedición de exploración
que estamos realizando alrededor de Saturno,
y en la que hemos estado estos últimos dos años y medio.
Saturno está acompañado por una gran colección de lunas muy diversas.
Su tamaño va desde unos pocos kilómetros de largo hasta el tamaño de los Estados Unidos.
De hecho la mayoría de las maravillosas imágenes que hemos tomado de Saturno
muestran el planeta acompañado de algunas de sus lunas. Aquí está Saturno con Dione,
y aquí está Saturno mostrando sus anillos de canto,
se puede ver lo estrechos que son verticalmente, con su luna Encélado.
Dos de las 47 lunas de Saturno destacan entre el resto.
Son Titán y Encélado. Titán es la luna más grande de Saturno,
y hasta que Cassini llegó allí
era la mayor extensión de terreno inexplorado
que quedaba en nuestro sistema solar.
Es un cuerpo celeste que ha intrigado durante mucho tiempo a los que han observado los planetas.
Tiene una atmósfera muy densa,
y de hecho se creía que las características de su superficie
serían más parecidas a las que tenemos aquí en la Tierra,
o al menos las que teníamos en el pasado, que a las de cualquier otro cuerpo del Sistema Solar.
Su atmósfera está compuesta en su mayoría por nitrógeno molecular, como lo que están respirando en esta habitación,
excepto porque también contiene
compuestos orgánicos simples como metano, propano y etano.
Esas moléculas en la zona superior de la atmósfera de Titán,
y sus productos se unen formando partículas de aerosol.
Este aerosol es omnipresente, global, rodea Titán completamente.
Y por eso es por lo que no podemos ver a través de la superficie
con nuestros ojos, en la región visible del espectro.
Esas partículas de aerosol, pensábamos,
antes de que llegásemos con Cassini, durante miles de millones de años
descendieron suavemente a la superficie y recubrieron la superficie
con una capa espesa de lodo orgánico.
Como si fuese el equivalente, el equivalente en Titán del alquitrán, o el petróleo; no sabíamos qué.
Pero eso era lo que sospechábamos. Y esas moléculas,
especialmente el metano y el etano, pueden ser líquidas a la temperatura superficial de Titán.
Así que resulta que el metano es a Titán lo que el agua es a la Tierra.
Puede condensarse en la atmósfera,
y reconocer este hecho abrió la puerta a
todo un mundo de extrañas posibilidades. Entonces, puedes tener nubes de metano,
y sobre esas nubes tienes cientos de kilómetros de aerosol
que evitan que la luz solar llegue a la superficie.
La temperatura en la superficie es de unos -212 ºC.
Pero, a pesar de todo ese frío, puedes tener lluvia sobre la superficie de Titán.
Y hace en Titán lo que la lluvia hace en la Tierra, talla barrancos, forma ríos
y cataratas. Puede crear cañones, puede acumularse en cuencas y cráteres.
Puede barrer el lodo de los picos y los valles de altas montañas
hasta las zonas bajas. Así que detente a pensar un minuto.
Intenta imaginar cómo es la superficie de Titán.
Está oscuro -el mediodía de Titán es como un crepúsculo oscuro en la Tierra.
Es fría, es misteriosa, es neblinosa,
podría estar lloviendo, como si estuvieras
en la orilla del lago Michigan pero éste estuviese lleno de aguarrás
Esa era la imagen que teníamos de la superficie de Titán antes de que llegásemos allí con la Cassini,
y puedo decirles que lo que hemos encontrado en Titán, aunque no coincide en todos los detalles,
es tan fascinante como la historia que he contado.
Y para nosotros ha sido (para el equipo de la nave Cassini)
ha sido como una aventura de Julio Verne hecha realidad.
Como he dicho tiene una atmósfera grande y densa.
Esta es una imagen de Titán retroiluminada por el sol, con los anillos de Saturno de fondo.
Y otra luna más ahí
-ni siquiera sé cuál es. Es una atmósfera muy extensa.
Tenemos instrumentos en Cassini que pueden ver la superficie
a través de su atmósfera, y mi sistema de cámaras es uno de ellos.
Y hemos tomado imágenes como esta.
Lo que se vé son zonas brillantes y zonas oscuras, y eso es todo lo que podíamos saber.
Fue muy desconcertante, no podíamos explicarnos lo que estábamos viendo en Titán.
Cuando miras esta región más de cerca empiezas a ver cosas
como canales sinuosos, que desconocíamos. Ves algunas formas redondeadas.
Esto, como descubrimos más tarde, es de hecho un cráter,
pero hay muy pocos cráteres en la superficie de Titán,
lo que significa que su superficie es muy joven.
Y algunas características parecen de origen tectónico.
Parece que han sido separadas por algo.
Siempre que veas algo lineal en un planeta,
significa que ha habido una fractura, como una falla.
Así que ha sido alterado tectónicamente.
Pero no podíamos encontrar ningún sentido a nuestras imágenes,
hasta que seis meses después de haber entrado en órbita
ocurrió un acontecimiento que muchos consideran
la cúspide de la investigación de Cassini en Titán.
Y esto fue el lanzamiento de de la sonda Huygens,
la sonda Europea que Cassini había transportado
durante siete años a través del sistema solar. La dejamos caer en la atmósfera de Titán,
el descenso le llevó dos horas y media, y aterrizó en la superficie.
Y quiero remarcar cuan importante fue este acontecimiento.
Esto es un aparato de construcción humana,
y aterrizó en el sistema solar exterior por primera vez en la historia de la humanidad.
Es tan importante que en mi opinión,
éste acontecimiento debió haber sido celebrado
con cabalgatas y confeti en todas las ciudades de Estados Unidos y Europa,
pero lamentablemente no fue el caso.
(Risas)
También fue importante por otra razón. Esta es una misión internacional,
y este acontecimiento fue celebrado en Europa, en Alemania,
los discursos de celebración fueron leídos con acentos ingleses,
y acentos americanos, y alemanes, y franceses, italianos y holandeses.
Fue una demostración viviente de lo que las palabras
"Naciones Unidas" deberían significar:
una verdadera unión de naciones juntas en un esfuerzo colosal por el bien.
Y en este caso, fue una enorme iniciativa para explorar un planeta
y llegar a entender un sistema planetario
que durante toda la historia de la humanidad ha permanecido inalcanzable
y ahora los humanos lo han tocado realmente.
Aquello fue -quiero decir, se me está poniendo la piel de gallina sólo de hablar de ello-,
fue un acontecimiento tremendamente emotivo,
y es algo que yo personalmente nunca olvidaré, y no deberían olvidarlo tampoco.
(Aplausos)
En fin, la sonda realizó medidas de la atmósfera durante su descenso,
y tomó también imágenes panorámicas.
Y no soy capaz de expresar cómo fue ver las primeras imágenes
de la superficie de Titán tomadas por la sonda. Y esto es lo que vimos.
Y fue muy impactante, porque tenía todo lo que queríamos
que las otras imágenes tomadas en órbita hubiesen tenido.
Era un patrón claro, un patrón geológico.
Es una red dendrítica que sólo pudo ser formada por el fluir de líquidos.
Y puedes seguir esos canales
y ver cómo todos convergen.
Convergen en este canal de aquí, que desemboca en esta región.
Estáis viendo una línea costera.
¿Era una costa de fluidos? No lo sabíamos.
Pero es algo parecido a una costa.
Esta imagen fue tomada a 16 kilómetros.
Esta es una imagen tomada a ocho kilómetros, ¿ok? De nuevo, la línea costera.
Ok, dieciséis kilómetros, ocho kilómetros... Eso es más o menos la altura de vuelo de una aerolínea.
Si realizas un viaje en avión a través de los Estados Unidos,
estarías volando a estas altitudes.
Así que éste es el panorama que visible por las ventanillas de las Aerolíneas de Titán
al volar por su superficie. (Risas)
Y finalmente, la sonda se posó en la superficie,
y voy a mostrar, señoras y señores,
la primera imagen de la historia tomada desde la superficie de una luna en el sistema solar exterior.
Y ahí está el horizonte, ¿bien?
Probablemente eso sean guijarros de hielo, ¿sí?
(Aplausos)
Y obviamente aterrizó en una de esas regiones planas y oscuras,
y no se sumergió fuera de vista. Por lo que no se posó en un fluido.
Donde la sonda aterrizo es básicamente
el equivalente Titánico de una planicie lodosa.
Esto es terreno no consolidado inundado de metano líquido
Y probablemente sea el caso que este material
se ha deslavado de los terrenos altos de Titán
por medio de estos canales que observamos,
y se ha drenado por miles de millones de años para llenar los cuencos bajos.
Y eso es en lo que aterrizó la sonda Huygens.
Pero aún, no había señal en nuestras imágenes,
o en las imágenes del Huygens, de algún cuerpo de fluidos grande y abierto.
Donde estaban? Se volvió aún más desconcertante cuando encontramos dunas.
Bien, este es nuestro vídeo de la región ecuatorial de Titán.
mostrando estas dunas. Estas dunas que tienen 100 metros de altura,
separadas por algunos kilómetros,
y continúan así por miles y miles de millas.
Hay cientas, hasta 1,000 o 1,200 millas de dunas (~1,800 km)
Este es el desierto del Sahara de Titán.
Obviamente es un lugar muy seco, o no se formarían dunas.
Así que nuevamente, se volvió desconcertante que no hubiesen cuerpos grandes de fluidos
hasta que finalmente vimos lagos en las regiones polares.
Y hay una escena de lagos en la región polar sur de Titán.
Es aproximadamente del tamaño del lago Ontario.
Y después, hace tan sólo semana y media,
sobrevolamos el polo norte de Titán y encontramos, de nuevo,
y encontramos un rasgo del tamaño del mar Caspio.
Así que parece que los líquidos, por alguna razón que no comprendemos,
o al menos durante esta estación, están aparentemente en los polos de Titán.
Y creo que estaréis de acuerdo en que hemos descubierto que Titán
es un lugar muy excepcional y místico. Es exótico, es alienígena, pero es también extrañamente similar a la Tierra,
y teniendo formaciones geológicas similares a la tierra
y una gran diversidad geográfica,
y es un mundo fascinante que tiene como rival único en el sistema solar
en complejidad y riqueza es la misma Tierra.
Y ahora vamos con Encélado. Encélado es una luna pequeña,
tiene aproximadamente un décimo del tamaño de Titán, aquí pueden verlo junto a Inglaterra.
Sólo es para enseñaros el tamaño; esto no pretende ser una amenaza.
(Risas)
Y Encélado es muy blanco, es muy brillante,
y su superficie está claramente quebrada, llena de fracturas,
es un cuerpo geológicamente muy activo.
Pero la veta madre de los descubrimientos en Encélado
fue encontrado en el polo sur -y estamos viendo el polo sur aquí-
donde encontramos este sistema de fracturas.
Y tienen un color diferente porque tienen distinta composición.
Están recubiertas. Esas fracturas están cubiertas con materiales orgánicos.
Además, toda esta región, la región polar sur
tiene elevadas temperaturas. Es el lugar más caliente del planeta.
Es tan extraño como descubrir que en Antártida en la Tierra hace más calor que en los trópicos.
Y después, cuando tomamos más fotos, descubrimos
que esas fracturas están despidiendo chorros de finas partículas de hielo
que se extienden cientos de kilómetros en el espacio.
Y cuando coloreamos esta imagen para hacer destacar los débiles niveles de luz,
vemos que los chorros forman un penacho,
que de hecho vemos en otras imágenes, que se extiende cientos de millas
en el espacio sobre Encélado.
Mi equipo y yo hemos examinado imágenes como esta,
y esta otra, y hemos pensado sobre los otros resultados obtenidos con Cassini.
Y hemos llegado a la conclusión
de que esos chorros podrían estar saliendo de bolsas
de agua líquida bajo la superficie de Encélado.
Así que tenemos, posiblemente, agua líquida, materiales orgánicos y calor en exceso.
En otras palabras, posiblemente hayamos tropezado
con el Santo Grial de la exploración planetaria moderna.
O en otras palabras, un entorno que es potencialmente apropiado para organismos vivos.
Y no creo que haga falta que les diga que el descubrimiento de vida
en alguna parte del sistema solar,
sea en Encélado o en otro lugar,
tendría enormes implicaciones científicas y culturales.
Porque si pudiésemos demostrar que el Génesis ha ocurrido
no una, sino dos veces independientes en nuestro Sistema Solar,
entonces eso significa, por inferencia, que ha ocurrido un asombroso número de veces
a través del universo y sus 13.7 mil millones de años de historia.
Ahora mismo, la Tierra es el único planeta que sabemos que está rebosante de vida.
Es preciosa, es única,
es, por el momento, el único hogar que hemos conocido.
Y si alguno de ustedes estaba alerta y consciente en los años 60
- y los perdonamos si no lo estaban, bien-
recordaran esta famosa imagen
tomada por los astronautas del Apolo VIII en 1968.
Fue la primera vez que la Tierra fue fotografiada desde el espacio,
y tuvo un impacto enorme en la percepción de nuestro lugar en el universo,
y en el sentido de responsabilidad para la protección de nuestro propio planeta.
Bueno, nosotros hemos tomado una imagen equivalente con Cassini,
una imagen que ningún ojo humano ha visto hasta ahora.
Es un eclipse total de Sol, visto desde el otro lado de Saturno.
En esta imposiblemente bella imagen
pueden ver los anillos principales retroiluminados por el sol,
se ve la imagen refractada del sol
y puedes ver también este anillo creado, de hecho,
por las exhalaciones de Encélado.
Por si no fuera lo suficientemente deslumbrante, podemos ver en esta bella imagen,
a nuestro propio planeta,
acunado en los brazos de saturno.
Ahora, hay algo profundamente conmovedor,
el vernos a nosotros mismos desde muy lejos,
y capturar la vista de nuestro pequeño y azul planeta acuoso.
en los cielos de otros mundos.
Y eso, así como la perspectiva que obtenemos de nosotros mismos debido a eso,
quizá, al final de cuentas, es el mejor premio que podemos ganarnos
de este viaje de descubrimiento que comenzó hace medio siglo.
Y muchas gracias
(Aplausos)